bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce qui
sera je l'espère notre saga de l'été une
série de vidéos sur la paléontologie des
vertébrés directement tirée des cours
que je donne à l'université du vide
bathurst rendre en afrique du sud dont
qui est une université à johannesbourg
et donc ses courses et des cours qui
sont à peu près niveau alors ce niveau
honors mais comme le niveau honors
n'existe pas en france en gros c'est un
niveau qui se trouve entre le niveau 3e
année de licence le niveau première
année de master donc ça équivaudrait au
niveau première année de master alors
c'est un cours de paléontologie des
vertébrés
il va falloir un petit peu de contexte
quand même c'est un cours déjà que je
donne dans un contexte d'introduction à
la biostratigraphie du caroux donc le
caroux c'est cette région en afrique du
sud qui équivaut à peu près à un tiers
voire la moitié de la surface de la
france et qui qui est complètement
truffé de faux cils qui vont du permien
jusqu au jurassique
donc c'est un cours qui va
essentiellement à introduire la
paléontologie du caroux est en général
qui présente la paléontologie sud
africaine donc ça à courre qui est fait
vraiment dans un contexte sud africain
et qui est africain en général donc vers
certains groupes qui sont représentés
que dans l'hémisphère nord dont je ne
vais pas parler qui sont extrêmement
connue en europe et en amérique parce
que pas parce que les bouquins en parle
beaucoup de ces groupes là alors je
pense notamment aux reptiles you more of
voilà les reptiles you more qui sont
généralement considérés comme les
ancêtres des amniotes je ne vais faire
que les effleurer parce qu'on en trouve
au cas sur le continent africain et
aucun même dans le gondwana si je ne me
trompe pas donc donc c'est un petit lion
mort
globalement je ne fais que les effleurer
alors qu'ils prennent une place très
importante dans les bouquins dans l'est
dans les cours qui sont donnés dans les
pays d'europe et en amérique
pourquoi bas parce que tout simplement
les bouquins sont écrits par des
américains et que eux ils ont plein de
reptiles you more voilà
mais nous on n'a pas de reptiles you
murphy si donc je n'y a pas vraiment
d'intérêt d'élaborer plus dessus
par contre j'ai d'abord beaucoup plus
sur les terres apside sur les premiers
dinosaures pas forcément ceux les plus
connus d'ailleurs j'élabore sur les
dinosaures du jurassique inférieur et
pas tellement sur les dinosaures du
crétacé qui sont justement les plus
connus donc c'est pareil les ceyrat
obtient typiquement dinosaures du
crétacé crétacé dont on a très très peu
de couches ici en afrique du sud datant
du crétacé on a très très peu de dépôts
qui datent du crétacé et qu'ils soient
terrestres en plus donc il n'y a pas
vraiment de chance d'avoir des
cératopsidés de toute façon c'est pareil
les ceyrat obtient c'est hémisphère nord
essentiellement je crois qu'il ya qu un
seul ceyrat obtient qui a dû être
trouvée en australie et encore ce n'est
pas sûr
mais bref voilà donc c'est encore des
groupes dont je vais pas parler donc
tricératops typiquement je vais survolé
donc voilà c'est un premier c'est une
première chose qu'il faut savoir à
propos de secours c'est que c'est dans
un contexte africain voire même sud
africain surtout mais évidemment vu que
je fais ce cours en français je vais
quand même moi même rajouté des petites
j'ai je vais saupoudré mais mes petites
connaissances sur le registre fossile
européen et français en particulier
quand je pense quand je pense que ce
sera pertinent ensuite la deuxième chose
à savoir donc il est en lien directement
avec la première c'est que je donne ça
dans un contexte de paléontologie du
caroux donc je ne peux pas tout couvrir
en tout c'est un court qu'il y aura huit
courts dont je vais essayer de faire ça
en cette vidéo
donc je ne peux pas tout couvrir en
cette vidéo
donc c'est donc ce n'est pas la peine de
me demander de couvrir plus certains
certains sujets c'est voilà je sais pas
possible de tout faire d'être exhaustif
cette vidéo il me semble que c'est
presque à peu près le nombre de vidéos
que j'avais fait juste pour la malle la
paléo mammalogie donc mon cours de paléo
mammalogie était très exhaustif et même
là j'avais pas le temps de couvrir pas
mal de champs de groupe de mammifères
qui sont pourtant importants
donc là il faut que je couvre toute la
paléontologie des vertébrés en un même
laps de temps donc ça va être compliqué
ça va être
ça va être impossible donc ça va
vraiment être une vue générale
voilà un squelette de connaissances et
c'est plus généralement ce que je dis
aux étudiants c'est que je leur donne un
squelette de connaissances et c'est à
eux de mettre la viande dessus quoi
c'est à eux de 2 mètres les muscles et
de mettre la peau et les organes quoi
donc sa demande quelques recherches en
soi mais c'est sa l'université surtout
au niveau master voilà et la troisième
chose à savoir c'est que je donne
secours avant que le cours de philo
génie et eu lieu donc la classification
que j'utilise dans ce cours est non
phylogénétique et c'est important ça va
être important de le rappeler parce que
c'est pas la peine de me faire un cours
de cladistique dans les commentaires je
connais la clac eastick ne vous en
faites pas c'est voulu c'est totalement
voulue pourquoi je ne fais pas ce cours
dans un contexte phylogénétique bas tout
simplement parce que les mots ce si napo
morphy plaisir morphy monofil éthique
par affi l'éthique poliphile éthique je
veux dire tout ce vocabulaire les
étudiants ne sont pas censés le
connaître du moins pas tous évidemment
il ya les étudiants qui viennent de
biologie auront normalement
un coin a un background phylogénétique
ils sauront ce vocabulaire là non pas qu
ils le maîtrisent mais ils sont censés
le savoir par contre les étudiants qui
viennent de géologie hisseront paumé
donc je ne peux pas utiliser de
vocabulaire phylogénétique parce qu'ils
n'ont pas encore ils ne sont pas encore
censés avoir eu ses cours donc ce que je
donne c'est la classification on va dire
entre guillemets traditionnel la
classification linnéenne et puis
évidemment je ne parle pas de sina paume
orfi donc voilà ça va être un court
c'est vraiment un cours d'introduction à
la paléontologie des vertébrés
voilà pour résumer ce petit disclaimer
c'est un cours d'introduction à la
paléontologie des vertébrés dans un
contexte africain
donc c'est vraiment juste voilà tendre
des perches et dire aux étudiants
saisissez les allez faire vos petites
recherches
allez lire des bouquins voilà lisez le
vertebrate paleontology de benton si
vous voulez en savoir plus
typiquement ou est typiquement le livre
de vertebrate paleontology de benton
c'est vraiment le le bouquin avoir sur
le côté quand vous quand vous suivez
secours parce que vous allez avoir des
infos complémentaires en fait parce que
voilà benton c'est typiquement le
bouquin qui a été écrit qui a été écrit
avec un background de paléontologues de
l'hémisphère nord donc vous allez avoir
des informations complémentaires sur ce
que moi je vais vous donner il ya
certaines informations que je vais vous
donner que vous trouverez dans aucun
bouc a donc
donc voilà c'est le petit disclaimer de
départ juste pour dire voilà pas de
phylogénie contexte africain et tout ça
est censé nous conduire à une
paléontologie du caroux et à la
biostratigraphie du caroux donc c'est
très focus sur les groupes qui sont
utiles pour la biostratigraphie du chaos
voilà donc ceci étant dit nous pouvons
commencer
donc on va évidemment commencer par
l'origine des poissons et c'est pour ça
que je disais en fait c'est pas la peine
de me faire un cours de classique je
sais très bien que les poissons ça ne
veut rien dire en cladistique mais nous
sommes dans un contexte non cladistique
donc je vais appeler les poissons les
poissons donc ceci est une chatte
géologique simplifiée avec le nom des
périodes sur la droite les dates ici en
les dates ici simplifiée j'ai pas des
fois enfin des fois j'ai donné vraiment
quand quand les dates étaient vraiment
bien bien définis genre 541 jeu les
données de 152 ici je les données mais
globalement s'est arrondi quand même on
va pas on va pas trop chipoter et ici
j'ai donné des ce qu'on appelle les faux
knowledge donc c'est vraiment une
introduction c'est pour donner aux
étudiants une introduction finalement à
la biostratigraphie ils ont déjà une
idée comme ça de ce que c'est que la
biostratigraphie dégâts en regardant
déjà ça donc on a une à un âge des
trilobites qui correspondait trilobites
qui correspond paléozoïque on a le
mésozoïque qui correspond aux dinosaures
et aux ammonites dans l'eau et on a
laissé nos amis qui correspond aux
mammifères aussi bien sur terre que dans
l'eau donc c'est ça donne déjà une idée
de comment on travaille là comment
marche la biostratigraphie
dès le départ et après on peut on peut
re subdiviser tout ça en période avec
les trois premières périodes cambrien
ordovicien silurien qui vont nous
intéresser donc généralement à ce niveau
là je dis aux étudiants que ça il n'ya
pas il ya pas à tortiller faut le savoir
par coeur au moins la partie à droite là
tout ça faut le savoir par coeur faut
savoir les dates parker ça va tomber à
l'examen bon ici
évidemment j'ai pas je vais pas exiger
de vous vous sachiez ça par coeur par
contre je vous conseille d'avoir une
petite fenêtre avec une une charte
géologique à lui mais à côté parce que
parce que je vais faire très très
souvent appel à tout ça et au donc dans
ce premier cours on va se focaliser sur
le cambrien à l'ordovicien le silure ya
évidemment tout est en anglais
c'est un cours que je donne en anglais
normalement donc mais bon ce jeu ça se
traduit très bien qu envoyer ordovicien
silurien et donc on va voir on va
focaliser là dessus donc en afrique du
sud
on trouve ces couches dans les montagnes
qui se trouve près du cap
donc voici le cap ici vous avez le
caroux et entre les deux il ya des
montagnes qui bloque l'humidité qui font
que le car ou est un désert alors que le
cap qui se trouve juste à côté n'en est
pas un et donc ces montagnes c'est là
qu'on va trouver le le cambrien
l'ordovicien silurien en france en
france ça correspondrait alors le sas et
la montagne noire dans le sud
vous avez le massif armoricain aussi qui
a donné pas mal de de ces couches là et
vous avez les ardennes encore que les
ardennes c'est plus en belgique qu'en
france mais il y en a un petit peu en
france quand même alors commençons déjà
par définir ce qu'est un vertébré donc
invertébrés c'est un animal qui a des
vertèbres surprise un des vertèbres oui
mais pas n'importe lesquelles elles sont
faites en apatite donc en fait les
vertébrés s'oppose aux invertébrés par
le fait que leurs squelettes n'est pas
externe
il est interne donc il est à l'intérieur
du corps contrairement aux invertébrés
les coquillages les crustacés les
insectes leur squelette est à
l'extérieur pour peu qu'ils aient un
squelette en dur évidemment donc ce
qu'on appelle un exosquelette les
humbles les vertébrés eux ont un
squelette interne et il est fait en
apatite qui est un faux spot 2
calcium contrairement aux invertébrés
qui généralement ont du carbonate de
calcium donc donc ces deux oppositions
vraiment intéressante d'un côté les
vertébrés squelette interne phosphate de
calcium et les invertébrés squelette
externe et carbonate de calcium
donc ça ça permet de faire la séparation
et ça permet de vous mettre
immédiatement face au concept que je
vais pas vous parler cladistique voilà
je vais pas vous parler phylogénétique
parce que si je sinon je devrais pas
parler d'invertébrés mais comme on n'est
pas dans un contexte phylogénétique on
peut séparer vertébrés et invertébrés
donc les vertébrés
ils ont des vertèbres et ses vertèbres
sous constitué de trois parties donc un
centre sommes dans lequel passe la
notochorde donc la notochorde c'est ce
qu'on retrouve chez tous les cordes et
c'est un espèce de d'échafaudages mou en
fait c'est un échafaudage ou qui sert de
weeds échafaudage à la colonne
vertébrale donc ils étaient présents
avant la colonne vertébrale chez est ce
qu'on appelle les cordées et il sert
d'échafaudages à la construction de la
colonne vertébrale qui elle est en
hausse et non pas en tissus mous et
autour vous avez un arc neural en eau et
un arc et mal en bas donc l'arc neural
sert au passage de la de la moelle
épinière et l'arc neural l'arc et mal
sert au passage de deux vaisseaux
sanguins essentiellement et évidemment
on retrouve cette colonne vertébrale
chez les poissons chez les reptiles chez
les amphibiens chez les oiseaux et chez
les mammifères incluant l'homme donc
l'homme fait bel et bien partie des
vertébrés puisque comme tous ces animaux
il a une colonne vertébrale donc jusque
là c'est plutôt simple alors maintenant
l'origine de ces vertébrés donc s'en
allait repousser jusqu'à jusqu au 2t
rostomia et aux échinodermes depuis ce
que les invertébrés les plus proches de
nous ce sont les échinodermes tout
simplement parce que leur développement
est très similaire au nôtre mais ça déjà
ça nous fait pas mal sortir du contexte
de secours on peut aller voir du côté
et d'écolo dont tu les connais donc donc
ce sont des les a longtemps connu de par
leur microfossiles donc c'est petit
ces petits morceaux là que vous voyez là
sans trop savoir à quoi ça correspondait
disons que comme ça ressemblait à des
dents on s'est dit que c'était des dents
bon quand on a fini par découvrir
d'écolo d'onde complet donc des animaux
kono donc on s'est rendu compte que ses
dents en fait c'étaient pas des dents
mais en fait ce sont des sondés
appartient à ce qu'on appelle l'organe
pharyngés donc l'organe du pharynx
ça c'est plus ou moins un truc qui
étaient attachées à leurs branchies on
va dire voilà c'est ici ici par exemple
donc sur promise homme qui vient
d'afrique du sud est qui est inconnu
dont deux complets un des très très rare
que nous donne complet qu'on est qu on
voit que cet organe pharyngés il n'est
pas loin des yeux donc il devait se
situer sur la tête
et puis il devait servir à filtrer
probablement le la nourriture a récolté
la nourriture à filtrer l'eau on va dire
et a récolté la nourriture de l'eau donc
des petites particules
avant d'envoyer tout ça dans le tube
digestif donc on voit qu'il ya encore
une note aux cordes chez ceux chez
promis sommes donc ce qui ce qui le
place dans la lignée des cordes et pas
loin des vertébrés et ce qui va le
placer un peu plus près des vertébrés en
fait c'est d'une part la chimie de ces
éléments phares âgés donc y ait ces
éléments falra gesson fait de phosphate
de calcium donc c'est de l'apatite donc
ça c'est un truc typique de vertébrés
que qu'on retrouve chez les cow 90 et
ils ont démis au maire c'est à dire des
muscles en v sur le corps et ses muscles
en v c'est pareil c'est typique de ce
qu'on retrouve chez les tous premiers
vertébrés donc par exemple en chine on a
mis le coup média et et haïkus ichthys
qui sont considérés comme les tous
premiers poissons ils ont des
millionnaires en forme de v donc des
muscles natatoire en forme de v qui
permet de bondues les donc c'est ce
qu'on voit ici sur cette reconstruction
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec ses
colombes c'est qu'ils sont très primitif
a cédé vers globalement ça ressemble à
un verre
et ça vous donne une très bonne image
d'ailleurs de ce à quoi les vertébrés
ressemblait tout au début ils
ressemblaient à des verts il n'avait pas
de nageoires il avait il avait tout
juste une queue un petit peu un petit
peu transformé en un joueur mais pas
complètement bon bref c'est les
vertébrés son descendant d'invertébrés
qui ressemblait globalement à des petits
verts même si c'était pas des verts il
avait juste cette différence qu'ils
avaient une note aux cordes quoi donc on
retrouve les écolos dont à partir du
cambrien jusqu au trias donc il t'a il
survivre quand même à la limite permise
trias mais c'est pas les ancêtres
directs des vertébrés c'est plutôt une
branche sur le côté mais qui nous montre
quand même à quoi les ancêtres des
vertébrés ressemblait donc maintenant
les vrais vertébrés donc les vrais
vertébrés qu'on pourrait appeler les
poissons bien qu' il n'y a pas que des
poissons chez les vertébrés il ya aussi
les tétrapodes qu'on va retrouver là du
côté sarko petit indien
est-ce qu'il faut d'abord voir avec les
vertébrés c'est surtout leur
classification donc la classification de
vertébrés elle est en quatre groupes les
aguias tu donc les poissons qui n'ont
pas de mâchoires les chondrites tient
des poissons cartilagineux les actes
ignobles terry gien les poissons à
nageoires rayonner et les sarko parisien
les poissons anna joueurs charnue les
sarko parisien les acti n'obtient rien
on les groupes ensemble chez eux dans le
groupe des poissons osseux qu'on oppose
au groupe des poissons cartilagineux
représenté par les chondrites tient et
les chondrites hien et les poissons
seront les groupes ensemble dans le
groupe des poissons à mâchoires qu'on
oppose au groupe des poissons sans
mâchoires que sont les aguias tu donc
c'est une classification qui est
relativement simple à mener at poissons
cartilagineux poisson à nageoires
rayonner poisson à nageoires charnue les
deux derniers on les oppose aux
cartilagineux en disant qu'ils sont au
ce et les trois derniers on les oppose
aux ags n'y attend dix ans que eux ils
ont une mâchoire
voilà c'était aussi simple que ça donc
on commence par les ags n'y est alors le
plus ancien à gjatsk on a ils datent du
cambrien c'est probablement les haïkus
ichthys et les millions coulent ninja
qu'on a retrouvée dans le cambrien de de
chine
en afrique du sud on retrouve le plus
anciens n'ont pas amené at mais le plus
ancien cycle ce tome donc les cycles ce
tome qui appartiennent aux ags niath ce
sont des ce sont en fait les l'emploi et
les mx in donc les lamproies et les mix
insee un groupe particulier daniate
qu'il se distingue des autres par sa
ventouse buccale
donc ils n'ont pas de mâchoire mais par
contre ils ont une ventouse ils ont
quand même une bouche même s'ils n'ont
pas de mâchoire évidemment ils ont une
bouche et ils ont une ventouse autour de
la bouche
et c'est devant tous buccale on la
retrouve sur un fossile qui s'appelle
prise commises ont et qui date du
dévonien d'afrique du sud du début du
dévonien supérieur donc c'est donc ce
c'est le plus ancien fossile de cycle au
sto mais les cycles ce tome sont
extrêmement rares puisque contrairement
à d'autres à xi'an qu'on va voir juste
après ils ont un corps qui est
complètement bout ils ont aussi cette
caractéristique les aniane ne pas avoir
de nageoires c'est comme les c'est comme
l'écho 90 en fait ils ressemblent
vraiment à d'écolo d'hondt
de ce point de vue là c'est un corps
très vermiforme quoi et les lamproies
sont des parasites et les mix in sont
des charognards et après vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de groupes daguenet
yade qui sont complètement éteint et
qu'on regroupe généralement sous le
terme austra codet remet donc les
hausses traque au derme c'est un groupe
qui n'est pas vraiment
phylogénétiquement reconnu mais qui
anatomiquement est très cohérent puisque
ça regroupe tous les poissons sans
mâchoires qui ont une armure qui ont un
bouclier sur la tête en fait donc ce
bouclier il est fait des cayes qui est
formée d'aspirine donc de la dentine et
de l'os ce qui par la même occasion vous
indique que le fait qu'ils aient de la
dentine dans ces cas il vous indique que
quand les dents vont évoluer la dentine
c'est en fait c'est les écailles qui
vont évoluer en dents qui vont devenir
les dents au moins les écailles qui
étaient autour de la bouche qui vont
devenir des dents et il ya de l'eau sous
silence et écailles on va voir que
chaque groupe de poissons qu'on va
explorer aujourd'hui à un type des cayes
différents donc c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt intéressant justement que juste à
part l'histologie
en fait des écailles on peut identifier
un groupe donc même si on retrouve des
cas isolés c'est pas trop grave
on peut quand même identifier quels
groupes on a face à nous donc ces
hausses traque au derme
on a on en retrouve beaucoup des cayes
on en retrouve aussi des plus complets
et quand on en a des plus complets on
sait aussi qu'ils avaient généralement
une queue hypo cercle donc c'est ce
qu'on retrouve chez les terrasses pido
mort fa qui sont les plus primitifs des
aguias tu donc là que hip auxerre que
c'est quand la colonne vertébrale dans
la queue pointent vers le bas et c'est
peut-être à speedo morph ils ont aussi
un bouclier kiné qui est formé de plein
des cayes qui ne sont pas fusionner donc
là vous voyez c'est comme ça ressemble à
une lamproie ses astra spis ça ressemble
un peu à une lampe roi mais cette
lamproie elle est recouverte de plein de
petits de plein de petites écailles en
as pikine et ses écailles donc elles ne
sont pas fusionner contrairement à ce
qu'on trouve chez les seifallah speedo
morph donc les céphalées speedo mov
c'est facile à reconnaître c'est ce qui
ressemblait à des aspirateurs parce
qu'ils ont de bouclier ils ont la tête
toute plate donc le bouclier céphalique
est tout plat et ça ça les fait
ressembler ouais un peu des aspirateurs
qui vivaient sur le fond et puis il
aspirait là il aspirait le sable ils
filtraient le sable et ccfa la speedo
mort ils sont un peu plus dérivés parce
que ils vont avoir plusieurs
caractéristiques qui vont d'abord leur
tête comme je les dis est fait d'un
bouclier qui est complètement ossifié
complètement fusionné
donc il ya plus de petites écailles
séparés comme ça ils ont la queue qui
pointe vers le haut qui ce qu'on appelle
la condition épices erc ou hétéro cercle
j'aime mieux j'aime mieux utiliser le
mot épi cercle que été re cercle bon jeu
après c'est une question de préférence
donc la queue et épices air qu'elle
pointe vers le haut et surtout ils ont
des nageoires pectorales donc c'est
l'origine des nageoires pectorales et
ces deux caractères et puis c'est requis
et nageoires pectorales ça les rapproche
des poissons des poissons à mâchoires
pourquoi parce que les poissons à
mâchoires comme les requins par exemple
ils ont une queue
pis erc généralement au moins
primitivement donc ils ont une queue
épis secs si vous penser à un requin là
que pointe vraiment vers le haut quand
vous regardez un requin il ya un lob qui
part vers le bas mais il est plus petit
et il ne contient pas la colonne
vertébrale et il est évidemment ils ont
des nageoires pectorales ce qui est une
innovation comparé à la condition que
vous pouvez voir là qui est la condition
vermiforme donc ça y est avec les cfl à
speedo morph les poissons ne sont plus
vermiforme voilà mais tous les deux ont
vécu de l'ordovicien au dévonien donc il
ya vraiment une diversité une explosion
de diversité des aguias tu qui a lieu de
l'ordovicien au dévonien tout ça va
disparaître en ne laissant derrière lui
que les mixes in et les lamproies et
d'ailleurs dont on va complètement
perdre la trace d'ailleurs dans le
registre fossile au passage c'est à dire
qu' il va y avoir une explosion de
diversité des aguias tu es ensuite c'est
c'est le c0 un calme plat jusqu'à
jusqu'aux groupes modernes en fait donc
c'est pour ça que souvent les mic signer
les lamproies sont qualifiés de fossiles
vivants ce n'est pas vraiment des
fossiles vivants
c'est juste qu'ils appartiennent à un
groupe qui s'est éteint et qui sait en
majorité étant ya très longtemps ça veut
pas dire qu'ils ont arrêté d'évoluer
entre deux donc le groupe suivant c'est
le groupe d nihat hostomme donc le
groupe des poissons à mâchoires qu'on
nous groupe qu'on oppose aux années at
les poissons sans mâchoires donc cette
mâchoire elle vient directement des
branchies d'ailleurs je peux revenir sur
cette image là puisque c'est là que je
le présente donc cette mâchoire elle
évolue directement à partir des arcs
branchaud en fait donc vous voyez le
premier arc branche sial ici représentée
en bleu et en orange qui devient en fait
le palato carré donc l'équivalent du
palais et de l'articulation de la
mâchoire
chez nous donc le plateau car et c'est
la mâchoire supérieure et qui devient le
cartilage de meckel qui est la mâchoire
inférieure est ici vous avez lio ide et
lio mandibulaire qui servent
d'articulation de la mâchoire chez la
plupart des poissons mais pas chez nous
chez nous lie aux idées lieu
mandibulaire vont former les vont former
les osselets de l'oreille moyenne ils
vont former une partie du pharynx et de
la glotte
ils vont former une partie du ce comme
aux halles mais ils sont exclus en fait
de l'articulation de la mâchoire chez
les mammifères pour des raisons qu'on va
voir bien plus tard tout à la fin les
mammifères sont bons sont probablement
les mois représentatif des vertébrés de
ce point de vue là quoi donc
mais pour l'instant sachez que chez les
poissons et même chez les premiers
tétrapodes 7 cette configuration est
très conserver puisqu'on va à chaque
fois trouvé une mâchoire supérieure à
une mâchoire inférieure anigo ide et
agneaux mandibulaire qui servent
d'articulation et tout ça est dérivée de
la 2d deux premières rangées en fait de
2 dark pharyngés et c'est ces arcs
branche chiot ou arc pharyngés ses arcs
branchaud on les retrouve quand même
chez l'embryon humain
donc on arrive à les revenus mais rod et
chez l'embryon humain et on peut suivre
leur destinée honte au gène ikke donc
leurs destinées de développement et on
les retrouve précisément là où on
s'attend à y retrouver à savoir que les
premiers à le premier arc bronchial
devient le le cartilage de pardon le
premier arc branche sial devient le
plateau car est le 2ème marque devient
le cartilage de meckel et puis vous
trouvez le yoyo mandibulaire bref c'est
évidemment c'est un peu plus dérivés que
celle et que l'image ultra simplifié que
je vous montre là un évidement mais
voilà vous avez la philosophie du truc
c'est que il y a des arcs branche chiot
mais au lieu de devenir des branchies
ils deviennent la mâchoire c'est ça
l'idée
et des fois on a des petites anomalies
de développement qui font que on a ce
qu'on appelle un spi racle c'est à dire
le leur est en fait de la branche ea de
entre le premier et le second arc
branche al donc ce qui correspond au spi
racle des requins c'est un petit trou en
fait et ce petit trou c'est le reste de
la branche y entre le 1er et le 2ème
marque qui n'est plus
vraiment fonctionnel encore que certains
poissons qui arrive à respirer à travers
cette cet arc et ben on le retrouve chez
certaines personnes par finalement
anomalies de développement mais bon
c'est une anomalie complètement bénigne
mais on le retrouve chez certaines
personnes donc le petit spi racle sinon
normalement le spi racle c'est en fait
votre tube de stage c'est l'équivalent
de votre tube de stage c'est à dire que
c'est un trou qui relie votre bouche à
l'extérieur mais sans passer par le nez
ou par la bouche voilà donc ça relire
votre bouche à l'extérieur sans passer
par le nez ni par la bouche bée ou
est-ce que ou est-ce qu'il va se troue
il va vers l'oreille
donc il s'ouvre dans le vôtre tympans en
fait donc aujourd'hui le tube de stage
il sert à réguler la pression intra à
l'intérieur de l'oreille moyenne
l'impression de l'air à l'intérieur de
l'oreille moyenne mais à l'origine en
fait c'est le spi racle des des poissons
enfin dès que vous voyez sur ce requin
par exemple et puis on va retrouver
évidemment chez seguier à tous comme les
nageoires pectorales et là que épi
cercle qu'on avait déjà chez les cfl à
speedo morts en plus de la présence
d'une mâchoire inférieure et supérieure
évidemment qui dit mâchoire ddans donc
ça va c'est aussi dans ce groupe là
qu'on va voir l'origine des dents sauf
chez un groupe qui s'appelle les plaques
au derme
donc commençons par les tout premiers
les tout premiers vertébrés à mâchoires
les tout premiers poissons à mâchoires
que sont les plaques au derme donc les
plaques au derme ce sont les poissons à
mâchoires avec une armure donc encore
une fois phylogénétiquement ça veut
probablement rien dire mais la même là
c'est encore extrêmement débattue la
position phylogénétique des plaques au
derme donc phylogénétiquement ça veut
probablement rien dire mais au moins
anatomiquement on sait ce qu'on regarde
quand on dit plaque au derme c'est un
poisson avec une mâchoire et une armure
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec les
plaques au derme c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
de dents et donc pendant très longtemps
on s'est demandé si cette absence dedans
c'était une absence primitive comme les
poissons sans mâchoires ou si c'était
juste il était repassé finalement un
stade primitif en ayant ils ont perdu
leurs dents quoi en fait si c'était une
réversion
donc là vous voyez par exemple d'un
kleos telus il n'a pas de dents ce sont
les eaux en fait donc le cartilage de
meckel ici est le plateau karecki ce qui
s'aiguisent l'un contre l'autre à chaque
fois que la mâchoire se ferment quand
ils ont des espèces de guillotine à la
place des mâchoires mais c'est de l'os
c'est pas 2 c'est pas de la dent donc
cette condition là elle peut tout aussi
bien voilà peut-être que chez les
plaques au derme chez les plaques au
derme ils ont décidé que les dents
c'était pas assez efficace valait mieux
avoir des guillotines à la place des
dents donc ça pourrait très bien être
une réversion est ce qui va ce qui va
aussi caractérisé les plaques au derme
c'est qu' il n'y a pas un bouclier mais
deux boucliers il y a un bouclier pour
la tête
donc il ya une armure pour la tête et il
ya aussi une armure pour la nuque armure
pour la nuque qui est l'équivalent de
nos épaules
donc votre ceinture votre ceinture
scapulaire s'est directement dérivée de
la nuque
l'armure nucale de ces lignes est aux
yeux de ses premiers gâteau ce tome on
pourrait presque y reconnaître ici voilà
une omoplate
on pourrait reconnaître ici des
clavicules bref voilà si on a envie de
jouer au jeu des homologie on pourrait y
trouver des homologie sans trop de
problèmes donc c'est à partir de ce plan
d'organisation là que le plan
d'organisation des vertébrés va
continuer à évoluer donc chez les dinos
tome en fâcher les plaques au derme
parlant on a deux groupes principaux
c'est pas les seuls évidemment mais en
tout cas c'est les deux seuls qui sont
représentés en afrique du sud
ces lézards trop dire et les antilles
arche donc et quand on distingue en fait
simplement par l'absence de ce qu'on
appelle le nuc al gap donc d'une fausse
nucale c'est à dire cette fausse que
vous voyez entre le crâne et le et le
bouclier de le bouclier de des épaules
le bouclier nucale pardon donc ce gap
nucale vous indique le célèbre d'un
kleos telus est un art trop dire donc de
la même manière que africana spis est un
art trop dire qui est plutôt marrant
puisqu'il a un genre d'ailerons alors
c'est pas un aileron comme les requins
c'est un aileron en hausse a donc il est
complètement osseux cet aileron vous
voyez une reconstitution ici
et ça c'est l'équivalent de dunks les
hausses telus finalement en afrique du
sud
on a aussi pas mal d'art trop dire en
france je crois pas qu'on ait dunks les
hausses telus par contre on attaque les
hausses telus en europe mais peut-être
pas en europe
apparemment non mais bref on a des arts
trop dire aussi en france mais je crois
pas qu'on est bien classé par contre
vous pouvez voir un très beau spécimen
de dunks les osthéos us si vous allez au
muséum à paris où je sais qu'à ghana
aussi à paléo police à gannat ils ont
aussi un joli un joli crâne de dunks les
osthéos us à vous montrer et puis vous
avez un deuxième groupe qui s'appelle
les antilles arche et qui n'a pas de gap
nucale vous voyez que la tête et le
corps sont complètement fusionné et qui
ont en plus un bouclier sur les
nageoires les nageoires elles font un
peu tronçonneuse même d'ailleurs donc on
pense que ses nageoires elle était aussi
fier parce que c'était un animal qui
vivaient sur le fond de l'eau vous voyez
qu'il est tout plat il vivait sur le
fond de l'eau il avait les yeux pointés
vers le haut donc il devait s'enterrer à
voir juste les yeux qui sortait et puis
quand les mars assez cher en fait ils
devaient se promener avec ses petits
bras ils devaient utiliser ses petits
bras pour aller d'une mare à l'autre en
fait donc cesser ses seins
[Musique]
disons que c'est l'hypothèse en vogue
voilà et donc c'est beau trio les pisse
africana mais on a aussi un beau trio
les pistes qui vivait au canada
donc ce qui montre que c'est quand même
des animaux qui étaient très très
répandu à l'époque et on a évidemment
aussi des antilles en europe les
poissons cartilagineux et là là il va
falloir vraiment se retenir pour pas
appeler ça des requins 1 parce que parce
qu'il en a marre de dire que les requins
il date du dévonien non les requins et
date pas du dévonien les premiers
requins ils apparaissent 6 alors que je
dise pas de bêtises je crois que les
tous premiers les toutes premières
traces d'éventuellement de trucs qu'on
pourrait appeler des requins c'est soit
le permien soit le trias mais en tout
cas c'est pas le devenir
les requins c'est pas des trucs qu'ils
sont
qui sont ces souvent des trucs qui sont
appelés des fossiles vivants alors que
les requins d'aujourd'hui au final ils
sont pas parus plus tard que enfin ils
sont pas apparus beaucoup plus tôt que
les mammifères en fait donc c'est une
idée qui font se retirer de la tête que
les requins que les requins sont des
fossiles vivants et très souvent le
problème vient du fait que et ça inclut
moi je dire je vais probablement mal ma
langue va probablement fourche et à un
moment et je vais au lieu de dire qu'on
drik tient ou poisson cartilagineux je
vais dire requins parce que ça vient du
fait que souvent on résume chondrites
tient à requins parce que c'est les plus
diverses des chondrites tient mais non
il y a aussi les raies et il ya aussi
les chimères qu'il faut prendre en
question donc attention à ça très
attention et même quand vous m'écoutez
voilà des fois je risque de dire requins
au lieu de dire poissons cartilagineux
c'est pas bien faut pas le faire donc
voilà les poissons cartilagineux
évidemment identifié par le fait que
leur squelette est totalement
cartilagineux donc il n'est pas question
d'avoir un gros casque aussi fier comme
celle et comme chez les plaques au derme
metz a une conséquence à ces fâcheuses
c'est que les fossiles sont plutôt rares
du coup du moins les fossile de
squelette complet ou de beau crâne sont
relativement rares donc ont finalement
on sait proportionnellement pas grand
chose comparé aux poissons aux poissons
avec un crâne complètement aussi fier
alors même qu'on en a encore aujourd'hui
des décombres il tient donc c'est
bizarre heureusement qu'on en a encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parce que sinon
on saurait vraiment rien des chondrites
tiens voilà donc ils sont évidemment
reconnaissables à leur alors nageoire
dorsale nageoire dorsale qui au moins
primitivement porte une épine même si
aujourd'hui la plupart des requins
blancs et des raies non plus les raies
ont toujours une nageoire mais elle est
plus vraiment dorsale part dans les rets
ont toujours une épine mais elle est
plus vraiment dorsale elle est plus sûre
la queue et il ya certains requins qui
ont des épines comme par exemple le
squale mais ça reste relativement rare
les chimères ont toutes une épine
par contre sur une épine sur le dos donc
sur leur nageoire dorsale donc mais par
contre dans chez les requins fossiles c6
est quasiment systématique vous avez
toujours une épine un souci à la
nageoire dorsale donc c'est plutôt ça
qui est marrant c'est la ctu c'est une
c'est une différence en fait à
l'intérieur des chondrites tiens c'est
juste les mêlées combrit tient moderne
qui ont tendance à perdre cette épine
sur la sur le sur la nageoire dorsale
donc voici un exemple de grosses épines
de nageoire dorsale qui vient du dé
venir d'afrique du sud qui est à peu
près qui est représentatif de ce qu'on
peut trouver de plus ancien de chez les
requins ça fâche et les voilà je fais
l'erreur chez les chondrites tiens donc
les chondrites tient les chondrites
tient date du dévonien et voici un des
plus anciens exemple mais il ya des cons
brickyard il ya des cadres y tient du
dévonien d'un peu partout y compris en
europe
on va voir un exemple on va voir des
exemples un peu plus tard est donc
laissée contre x hier ils sont aussi
caractérisée et surtout j'ai envie de
dire caractérisés par leur dans leurs
écailles qui sont constitués en fait de
la même manière
donc une couche d'émail que les
spécialistes préfèrent appeler et nam et
loide que emai
mais bon ça revient à la même chose
c'est une couche d'émail une couche de
dentine et la pulpe est en fait vous
vous rendez compte que ces écailles
elles sont exactement constitué comme
des dents en fait c'est de la pulpe de
la dentine et de l'émail donc ses dents
et ses écailles sont faites exactement
de la même manière le nom des écailles
ce sont les écailles placo id donc très
typique des poissons cartilagineux qui
diffère de la speed ink on a vu tout à
l'heure par le fait qu'il n'ya pas d'os
contrairement à l'as pikine de tout à
l'heure et puis elles ont cette forme
très fuselées qui donne au rockhal leur
hydrodynamisme et les dents des requins
elles ont cette particularité aussi donc
de déjà de montrer que les dents sont
directement dérivés des écailles ou ce
sont des écailles transformer et elle se
l ont cette particularité de se
renouveler en tapis roulant en fait donc
il ya des générations sur génération de
dante
ils n'arrêtent pas de se renouveler tout
le temps donc c'est très différent de ce
qu'on voit chez les mammifères ou là il
ya que deux générations de dents qui se
succèdent là vous avez des dizaines de
dizaines voire pourquoi pas même des
centaines de générations de dents qui se
succèdent un requin peut perdre un
requin moderne peut perdre jusqu'à 10000
dans dans sa vie donc et ça par contre
c'est une aubaine pour les
paléontologues parce que à défaut de
trouver beaucoup d'os on va trouver
beaucoup de dents de requin foie de
poisson cartilagineux donc ça c'est 13
heures ça c'est très intéressant pour
nous et donc ça ça ne se retrouvent que
chez les poissons cartilagineux les
cailles plaques aux ide et le
remplacement dentaire en tapis roulant
la queue et épices erc donc ça c'est
primitivement hérité directement des
seifallah speedo morph les d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure mais les les
plats coderre mon hocine que épices erc
ça se voit sur ces illustrations là donc
c'est vraiment le caractère primitif la
queue épices herbes pour les pour les
lignes atos tom donc pour les poissons à
mâchoires et les chondrites tiens sont
carnivores donc l'origine maintenant des
chondrites tiens c'est un c'est un chant
qui est très très très débattue donc je
ne vous garantit pas que ce que je vous
présente aujourd'hui sera encore valides
au moment où vous le verrez mais en tout
cas c'est l'état de l'art au moment où
je vous le dis donc pour l'instant le
plus vieux chondrites ya reconnu aide au
lieu du ce du début du dévonien comme je
vous le disais les chondrites ya
apparemment son sont apparus au dévonien
on a des petites écailles qui pourrait
on a des traces des cayes plaques aux
ide qui pourrait faire remonter
l'origine des chondrites tient jusqu'au
6 lui rien mais vous allez voir pourquoi
c'est pas totalement pris au sérieux
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi juste
après donc là pour l'instant on va
parler de dole iodus donc do you do il a
le remplacement dentaire très typique
des chondrites ya avec ce tapis roulant
voilà qui est très visible ici donc ça
il n'y a pas trop de doutes sur le fait
que c'est un conte briques tiens
le corps est totalement cartilagineux il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de casque il
n'y a pas de protection d'armures et on
a sur les nageoires pectorales sur les
nageoires pectorales donc il ya des
nageoires pectorales des lost
intéressant à savoir et sur les
nageoires pectorales on va avoir un truc
qui n'est pas commun du toucher les
chondrites tient mais qui est très
intéressant pour discuter de leur
origine c'est la présence des pin
donc je vous ai dit qu'il avait des
épines sur les nageoires dorsales
mais pas sur les nageoires pectorales
donc là ça se voit bien sûr le fossile
ici sur le côté la couleur est dû au
fait que c'est une lumière uv si je me
trompe pas mais voilà sur le côté vous
voyez ces deux nageoires pectorales avec
leurs épines et ça c'est pas commun du
tout pour un condrieu tient par contre
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve chez
un autre groupe qu'on appelle les a
quand odien ou les requins épineux alors
on les appelle des requins épineux mais
ils n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec
les requins au final déjà parce que
comme j'ai dit ça en revient encore une
fois appelé les chondrites ya des
requins mais bon c'est le nom commun
qu'on leur donne
j'y peux rien c'est pas moi qui ai
décidé ça en revient encore une fois à
faire des requins les représentants des
cons briques tient depuis depuis le
dévot lien alors que c'est pas le cas
mais bref c'est un quotidien où ils
n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec des
chondrites hier de manière générale déjà
parce qu'ils ont un opercule et les rues
et les chondrites tient n'ont pas dopé
recule donc penser aux requins par
exemple les requins ils ont leur leurs
branchies qui sont totalement exposés
sur le côté vous voyez les branchies des
requins alors que si vous regardez un
poisson je suis pas un ton un maquereau
ou je ne sais quoi vous ne verrez pas
ses branchies parce qu'il ya un opercule
par dessus qui les protègent et 7 aux
percus peut faire des petits battements
pour faire circuler l'eau un requin lui
il faut qu'ils nagent tout le temps
parce qu'il n'a pas dopé reculé que
sinon bah l'ol circule pas dans ses
branchies quoi donc il faut qu'il bouge
tout le temps leur cas parce que il n'a
pas dopé recul justement donc et les à
canto dhien ils ont un opercule donc ça
aurait tendance à les exclure totalement
de la parenté des des poissons
cartilagineux ils ont un corps qui est
osseuse qui tendrait aussi à les exclure
totalement de la parenté des poissons
cartilagineux mais par contre ce qu'ils
ont fait
des écailles plaques aux ide et ils ont
aussi donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ça pose
problème parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
savoir si les écailles placo id du
silurien appartiennent à des acanthes
odien ou à des vrais contre iqt ya donc
ça c'est un premier problème est le
deuxième truc c'est que il ya certains
certaines espèces notamment du genre
thomas cantus qui ont un système de
remplacements dentaire en tapis roulant
comme les chondrites tient et on
retrouve ces acomptes indien du silurien
jusqu au permien donc donc c'est pour ça
que je vous disais le problème des
écailles placo id du silurien c'est que
parcimonieusement on a envie de les
attribuer plutôt à des 50 au diable
parce qu'on sait qu'on a des acanthes
odien aussi lui rien on n'a pas que des
écailles on a des on a des défauts s'il
plus complet on sait qu'il ya des
acanthes odien aussi lui rien et on sait
qu'ils ont qu'ils peuvent avoir des
écailles placo id donc ça pose problème
tout ça donc la grande question c'est
est ce qu'on place les à canto dia du
côté des poissons ce à cause de leurs
squelettes osseux et de l'europe et
reculées où est-ce qu'on place plutôt du
côté des chondrites tient à cause de
leurs écailles plaques aux ide et de
leur remplacement dentaire ballack est
la réponse pour l'instant c'est on sait
pas et probablement les deux c'est à
dire que les à canto dia et il est fort
probable que les acomptes odien et soit
les ancêtres d'un peu tout le monde des
soins en fait un gros groupe poubelles
dans lequel on a mis des ancêtres d'un
peu tout le monde est dans ce qui nous
intéresse la dans le cadre de dole iodus
c'est qu'il ya un truc en plus
maintenant qu'on peut relier qui permet
de relier les uns quand o dia au congrès
tient et c'est la présence des pin sur
les nageoires puisque à canto dia
signifie épineux véritable épineux pour
le coup les véritables épineux et pour
le coup et c'est ça leur vient du fait
qu'ils ont des épines absolument partout
ils ont des épines sur les nageoires
dorsales sur les nageoires
cloaca lé sur les nageoires pelvienne
sur les nageoires pectorales bref ils
ont des épines sur absolument toutes les
nageoires les accords d'audience et de
lax que leur vie à leur nom est là et
donc incluant des nageoires pectorales
comme do you do donc ça ce serait un
autre caractère qui relierait c'est un
canton diao chondrites tiens mais bon
comme je disais c'est probablement les
ancêtres d'un peu tout le monde et de
personne à la fois donc là vous avez un
exemple d'un quotidien du dévonien de
d'afrique du sud donc avec préservation
des tissus mous en plus donc très jolie
celui très très joli
donc voilà où on voit là où on se tient
au niveau classification c'est alors on
a vu l'origine avec dolio du ce ici donc
la base on a vu les caractères qui
permettent de caractériser les
chondrites tiens donc là le remplacement
dentaires les écailles placo id
peut-être une origine parmi des certains
au moins à quand odien et donc là on va
plonger dans cette classification des
décombres il tient avec les trois
groupes modernes que sont les ré les
bateaux id laisser là qui mord phares
que sont les requins les olo céphale que
sont les chimères et on va voir un peu
comment ça se relit avec des groupes
complètement éteint d'autres d'autres
poissons cartilagineux donc commençons
par les olo céphale donc les chimères
dans les chimères bas c'est déjà ça fait
partie des espèces qui nous embête pas
ce que c'est les exceptions voilà le
remplacement dentaire en tapis roulant
et perdu chez les chimères donc leur
temps et leur dentition est hyper
simplifiée vous avez juste deux pères
deux plaques une paire à l'avant qui
donne des incisives de rongeurs et une
paire à l'arrière sur le palais qui
broie les coquilles et voilà et ses
dents ne sont jamais remplacer elle
pousse en continu en fait
donc ça fait s'ils sont embêtants les
chimères et sera embêtant ils veulent
pas faire comme tout le monde
par contre il conserve certains traitent
primitif des causeries tient comme la
présence d'une épine sur la nageoire sur
la nageoire dorsale et cette épine est
particulièrement longue chez les
chimères et on a relié beaucoup beaucoup
de groupes à ses chimères
aujourd'hui il reste plus beaucoup enfin
il n'y a pas une grosse grosse diversité
de chimères et c'est plutôt un groupe
qui vit dans le dans les océans profond
donc c'est vraiment une
c'est vraiment un groupe qui se planque
qui a survécu parce qu'il s'est planqué
dans une dans une niche écologique où on
n'allait pas trop l'embêter en fait mais
par contre il ya beaucoup de groupes du
paléozoïque qui ont été reliés aux
chimères donc selon quels groupes du
paléozoïque a été réellement reliés aux
chimères il est possible que ces
chimères a été très diversifiée par le
passé donc dans les candidats célèbres à
l'ancestralité des chimères vous avez
lait les oeufs généraux d'anti forme
donc par exemple hélico priant qui est
très célèbre avec sa cédant spirale
enfin c'est d'en organiser sur une
mâchoire en spirale qu'on sait pas trop
d'ailleurs comment interpréter donc ça
fait partie des candidats possibles aux
ancêtres des olo céphale et vous avez
les six maury forme comme d'hui casser
la cus donc dû casser les six maury
forme déjà qu'ils sont reconnaissables
par leur brosse dorsale donc c'est la
nageoire dorsale qui s'est transformé en
ce truc un peu plat et les épines
ensuite et les écailles plaques aux ide
qui se sont transformés en brosse en
fait cette brosse dorsale est très
connue vous la retrouvez notamment chez
fall catus d'amérique du nord par
exemple et ccimo reform seraient reliés
aux chimères par louis casser la cus
donc du permien du début du permien
d'afrique du sud parce que depuis qu à
celles accusant fait il a une très très
grande
orbit et donc il serait déjà adapté à
vivre dans le fond des océans comme le
sont les chimères moderne
ça pourrait tout aussi bien être une
convergence évolutive une adaptation
parallèle à vivre dans le fond des
océans mais en tout cas bon de lui
casser la cus a été trouvé dans un
environnement d'estuaire donc ça semble
pas être liée à son environnement donc
c'est peut-être un caractère un
caractère bel et bien partagée entre les
olo céphale et louis casser la cus donc
voilà de deux origines possibles parmi
tant d'autres que je vous expose là
comme je disais j'ai pas le temps de
couvrir tout bref et en afrique du sud
on a un autre candidat possible pour les
ancêtres des chimères qui est plesius et
la cus donc plaisir c'est la cus dont un
fossile qui une fois encore préserve
totalement le corps semble suggérer
qu'il avait une longue épine dorsale et
une queue qu'on dit difficile qu'a donc
dit fiscal ça veut dire qu'en fait la
colonne vertébrale et horizontale et si
cette colonne vertébrale est horizontale
enfin la colonne vertébrale horizontale
comme ça c'est aussi un caractère qu'on
retrouve chez les olo ses fans le
problème c'est que les yeux c'est la cus
vient du carbonifère d'afrique du sud et
que dans le carbonifère et qu'il vient
une fois de plus d'un environnement
d'estuaire le même environnement que que
pour louis casser la cus et que dans les
estuaires et dans les eaux douces du
carbonifère on a un autre groupe qui
s'appelle les xena quand idées et qui
ont exactement ces mêmes
caractéristiques à savoir la longue
épine dorsale est la colonne vertébrale
horizontale
donc on n'est pas beaucoup plus avancé
donc et je ne sais pas d'ailleurs qu'il
faudra vérifier s'il y a des gens qui
ont proposé que l'eczéma quand pouvaient
être les ancêtres des olo céphale je ne
pense pas parce que les comme je les dis
vive dans le fond des océans alors que
les l'eczéma quand était définitivement
des décombres il tient d'eau douce donc
à voir
on a beaucoup d'ailleurs de ces xena
quand en france notamment le gisement de
hautain
tout ce qui vient du charbon en fait le
charbon du massif central les gisements
qui ordonnait le charbon du massif
central ont aussi donné de très très
beaux exemples de xena quand idée on
monte un petit peu on monte un petit peu
plus près des requins moderne et des
raies moderne avec les ibo dont il forme
alors les ibode anti forme ce sont les
les requins entre guillemets parce
qu'ils ont une forme générale de requins
ne se sont pas encore des requins mais
ce sont les poissons cartilagineux on va
dire typique du mésozoïque donc ce sont
les laits vraiment les les poissons
cartilagineux dominant du trias et du
jurassique qui vont se faire ensuite
remplacée durant le crétacé il ya
beaucoup de gisements crétacé qui donne
des véritables requa et non pas des
e-bonds nantis forme donc on voit ce
remplacement en fait se faire au cours
du crétacé entre les e-bonds qui forment
et les requins moderne mais les e-bonds
anti femmes sont vraiment les requins
requin ou encore une fois entre
guillemets typique du mésozoïque et ils
sont caractérisés par le fait qu ils ont
d énormes épines sur le dos vraiment des
très très grosse épine avec des stries
iations très caractéristique et ils sont
aussi caractérisée par la présence de
cornes sur leur tête
donc ils ont des écailles placo id
transformer en cornes sur la tête qui
sont très très typique des e-bonds
outils forme encore qu'on les trouve pas
chez tous les ébouillanter forme et
saisi pendentif en forme ils sont
intéressants ils sont intéressants dans
un contexte de l'évolution des décombres
il tient parce que ce sont les premiers
chondrichtyens à avoir ce qu'on appelle
une nageoire tribales
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'une hache
meurtri basale une nageoire tribales en
fait c'est c'est quand ça dépend du
nombre d'os qui attachent votre
nageoires à votre épaule donc une
nageoire mono basale comme par exemple
les ont les chimères c'est une nageoire
où il n'y a qu'un seul os qui attache la
nageoire à l'épaule c'est ce qu'on voit
chez les chimères les e-bonds dont ils
forment par contre eux ils ont une
nageoire tribal c'est à dire qu'il ya un
deux trois os qui s'attache
à la nageoire qui s'appelle le pro terry
j le propre des régions comme le
mésothéliome est le méta terry j m et
ces trois hauts de la nageoire on
retrouve ça chez les requins moderne et
chez les rênes moderne donc c'est un
caractère qui rapproche les e-bonds dont
ils forment en fait des espèces modernes
donc qui nous suggèrent que les espèces
modernes sont soit très proche cousine
des e-bonds dont ils forment soi même
directement descendre descendante des
e-bonds d'anti forme et ces e-bonds
d'anti forme ils ont une origine très
très profonde dans le palais aux olic
puisque le plus vieux d'entre eux c'est
au nico c'est là qu'est qu'on retrouve
dans le carbonifère entre autres
d'afrique du sud avec encore une fois un
très très beau spécimen très très bien
préservé avec les tissus mous voyez la
colonne vertébrale ici vous voyez la
nageoire de la nageoire dorsale avec les
pin ici et après bon la photo est pas
génial mais normalement vous êtes censé
pouvoir voir tout ça voilà là on a la
nageoire ici de les caractères les plus
importants c'est quand même la nageoire
ici avec les 1 2 3 aux donc on voit bien
la nageoire tryba than quand même et là
on voit une des cornes
ici c'est la grosse corde que vous voyez
là on voit une des cornes sur la tête
donc on est bien face à un niveau d'anti
fort mais on est bien face un quelque
chose qui est déjà plus proche de la
condition qu'on retrouvera plus tard
chez les ch et les poissons
cartilagineux moderne
ce qui nous amène à ces fameux poisson
cartilagineux moderne qu'on appelle les
néo sélaciens donc ce sont les requins
et les raies donc les requins et les
raies sont plus proches l'un de l'autre
qu'ils ne le sont d autres chondrites ya
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas appeler
les autres chondrites ya des requins
parce que si vous dites que hélico
prions par exemple ou bien qu'on en a vu
tout à l'heure plesius et la cus oudry
casser la cus si vous dites que ces
choses là sont des requins ou même les
ibode anti forme d'ailleurs si vous
dites que ces choses là sont des requins
et bien en fait ça veut dire que tous
les conducteurs sont des requins donc ça
veut dire que les ré aussi sont des
requins
et appeler une ré un requin ça fait
chier
voilà il ya des mots pour décrire les
choses et on va pas a plaidé faut
appeler un chat un chat un chien un
chien et si on se met à dire que tout
est un choc
on n'avance à rien voilà les
classifications sont faits pour être
utile si on si on si on les rend
inutiles en utilisant les mauvais mots
ben on perd complètement la saveur de l
utilité de ces classifications et la
beauté surtout de ces classifications
donc bref les néo sélaciens ces néo
sélaciens donc ils ont comme je le
disais tout à l'heure généralement ils
ont perdu leurs épines sur le dos à part
quelques groupes notamment les raies qui
ont encore une épine sur la queue et les
squales par exemple qui ont aussi une
épine dans sur le sur la nageoire
dorsale mais par contre ils ont aussi
ils ont des nouveaux des choses
nouvelles
des innovations est notamment la
présence de trois couches de d'émail
plutôt que d'une donc ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est justement de suivre
l'évolution de ces trois couche d'émail
donc chez tous les chondrites tiens vous
avez une couche d'émail
donc c'est la couche d'émail dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est normal on la
retrouve aussi sur les écailles placo id
ensuite chez certains ibo d'hondt et
chez les néo sélaciens vous avez deux
couche d'émail donc là et c'est le et la
pf veut le voyez ici et chez les néo
sélaciens uniquement vous avez trois
couche d'émail
par contre ce schéma il est mignon mais
les raies ont tendance à perdre au moins
la troisième voire les deux dernière
couche d'émail et à retourner finalement
à l'état primitif donc les réelles sont
un petit peu embêtante de ce point de
vue là mais bon disons que c'est
globalement accepté que la présence de
trois couche d'émail étaient au moins
primitivement une innovation chez les
néo sélaciens avant d'être perdue
secondaire manche et les rays ceci dit
on n'est pas à l'abri que dans un futur
proche quelqu'un annonce qu'en fait
c'est que les requins qui ont trois
couche d'émail
on a aussi chez les néo sélaciens donc
puisqu'on ne peut pas se fier que bon
nombre de couche d'émail
on va aussi on a aussi d'autres
caractère intéressant et notamment le
fait que la bouche
soit en dessous de la tête chez les ch
et les requins et les raies
si vous regardez de si on retourne par
exemple ici à nosy-be aux nantis forme
vous voyez que la bouche elle est à
l'avant du museau alors que chez les
requins et les raies vous avez un espace
de rostre bon là il est évidemment
extrêmement prononcée mais vous avez
cette espèce de rostre et la bouche se
trouve attendant que voilà elle se
trouve en dessous de la tête en fait
elle se trouve pas à l'avant de la tête
et ça c'est typique des requins et des
raies c'est typique des néo sélaciens et
c'est lié à l'articulation you stilic de
la mâchoire donc primitivement rappelez
vous on a le plateau car et on a le nez
on a le cartilage de mais quel est donc
le plateau carré est accroché au crâne
il est accroché au crâne directement
mais il est aussi accroché au crâne par
le lion mandibulaire et le lie aux ide
est bien là non il n'ya que lio
mandibulaire ici qui est accroché au
palato carré et au crâne par contre le
plateau karine est plus accroché au
crâne chez les néo sélaciens et ça ça
leur permet de projeter la bouche vers
l'avant donc c'est ce que vous voyez ici
donc lyon mandibulaire en fait sert de
pivot et permet de projeter la mâchoire
vers l'avant ce que vous pouvez voir ici
sur ce requin je crois que c'est un
requin lutins mais peu ça n'a pas
vraiment d'importance l'important c'est
vraiment de voir que cette suspension
you stilic de la mâchoire est typique
des néo sélaciens donc les néo sélaciens
sont les seuls à pouvoir projeter leurs
mâchoires
parmi les chondrites tiens on va voir
que cette ça va aussi évoluer chez
d'autres poissons et puis caractère
surprenant pour un poisson cartilagineux
le centrum des vertèbres donc vous
rappeler la partie la partie du milieu
de la vertèbre le centrum des vertèbres
est aussi fier chez les poissons
cartilagineux donc ça fait bizarre ça
fait bizarre à dire mais c'est seulement
chez les néo sélaciens donc ça peut vous
arriver si vous vous promenez sur la
plage de retrouver des petits centres
sommes deux vertèbres
comme ça isolé bas ce sont des 132
vertèbres de requins et vous pouvez
aussi les trouver dans le registre
fossile d'ailleurs donc voilà les plus
anciens les plus anciens néo sélaciens
qu'on connaisse date possiblement du
permis à voir même du carbonifère mais
c'est très débattue en fait puisque ce
ne sont que des dents les premiers
fossiles dont on est vraiment sur ces
permis un trias voilà donc avec une
bonne chance que d'une origine durant le
permien mais ouais on a quelques restes
qui voudraient faire repousser l'origine
de ces de ces poissons cartilagineux
jusqu'au carbonifère voire même jusqu au
dévonien
mais comme une fois de plus ce sont que
des dents donc il est possible que ce
soit des dents de deux groupes typique
plus typique du paléozoïque qui soit qui
ait évolué de façon convergente vers la
morphologie plus néo c'est la sienne
donc c'est très débattue mais par contre
les groupes modernes
eux ils sont originaires plus du milieu
du mésozoïque donc un peu comme les
mammifères qu'en fait ils ne deviennent
réellement abondant co ceo nick très
très abondant consignes aux os x encore
une fois un peu comme les mammifères
donc encore une fois n'appelez pas un
requin fossile vivant s'il vous plaît
évidemment ces néo sélaciens on peut les
diviser en deux les requins et les raies
donc laissé là qui mord pas les bateaux
id
les requins ont des dents plutôt pointus
les raies ont des dents plutôt plate
c'est assez simple à identifier
tout simplement parce que les a sont des
carnivores qui chassent des poissons et
aussi à l'occasion des mammifères marins
comme par exemple le fameux megalodon
alors que les raies sont plutôt des
animaux du rov âge c'est à dire qu'ils
vont manger des coquillages des
crustacés etc
des petits invertébrés avec deco qui
très dur évidemment on ne peut pas
parler des sélaciens sans parler de
megalodon donc le fameux méga c'est la
cus autobus megalodon méga c'est la cus
megalodon c'est comme vous voulez ou
auto du smega c'est la cus megalodon ça
va en fait c'est pas comme vous voulez
mais ça dépend réellement de qui vous
lisez
en fait c'est en fonction des auteurs et
en fonction de leur origine géographique
surtout vous allez avoir des noms
différents
les américains par exemple n'arrive pas
à se résoudre à appeler le megalodon
autrement que kar kar au cnes megalodon
les vieux de la vieille vous diront même
carcharodon megalodon en le plaçant du
coup dans le même genre que le requin
blanc bon ça ici à une au moins une
chose dont on est sûr c'est que enfin
tient une moins une chose sur lequel
tout le monde s'accorde aujourd'hui
c'est que le megalodon et le requin
blanc ne sont pas directement apparentés
le requin blanc a des ancêtres dans le
genre ysu rue ce qu'on appelait
autrefois cosmopolite au bus alors que
le megalodon a des ancêtres dans le
genre autobus qu'on peut retracer jusqu
au crétacé donc c'est pas du tout les
mêmes branches en fait c'est pas du tout
la même branche donc le megalodon n'est
pas l'ancêtre du requin blanc par contre
fonctionnellement parlant les dents sont
assez similaires ça faut bien l'avouer
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on
s'arrête avec les poissons cartilagineux
et la prochaine fois on parlera des
poissons osseux et de la fameuse sortie
des eaux et de ce que ça veut réellement
dire à très bientôt